[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity the Trump agenda speaking at the
Obama Foundation this week former
President Obama took a thinly-veiled
swipe at President Trump saying
America's progress is hindered by quote
hate anger racism and mommy issues you
can't make this stuff up take a look the
reason we don't do it is because we are
still confused blind shrouded with hate
anger racism mommy issues in a 2014
interview with former President Bush
Hannity asked him why he consistently
refused to criticize his successors take
a look at his response why did you make
the decision I mean I could sit here all
day and try and get you to comment on
President Obama and I'm not gonna get
anywhere correct because I've known you
I know you're very what you do why did
you make that decision because I'm sure
you have a lot to say and have you're
not getting you were we've talked
politics before we came in you were very
engaged together what's going on I'm
very aware of what's going on I don't
think it's good for the country to have
a former president undermine a current
president I think it's bad for the
presidency for that matter and joining
me now with reaction Salem radio talk
show host Larry elder and former chair
of the Council of Economic Advisers to
President Obama
Austan Goolsbee good evening gentlemen
you know it is rather shocking that a
president would come out and criticize a
president the way we've seen President
Obama do it so I am going to start with
you Austin you know there's a book the
president's club which I'm sure you're
familiar with and it documents the the
unique relationship between presidents
where you know the the the sitting
president will have communications with
foreign presidents because their
experience is so unique having shared
the Oval Office and those those
incredible decisions and burdens that
they carry
and so there is a relationship that they
have but Oh President Obama from the
last week or two that he you know of the
race he took every day to go out and
campaign against Donald Trump he did it
in the midterms it's unheard of is it
good for the country as George Bush just
said well I think he kind of makes two
things I think for sure in look it's
this Thanksgivings tomorrow in the
spirit of Thanksgiving let's hope that
everyone tones down the kind of personal
rhetoric and to refer to mommy issues I
think stuff like that is is beyond
bounds what would people say if I refuse
I refuse or daddy issues yeah but that
way judge the thing is you know that
this is in the context of the President
of the United States now saying some
outrageous things what is he - he's well
for example President Trump calling it
President Obama the most ignorant
president in the history of America and
what did he do President Obama was not
born in this country things about the
present oh come on okay so you're
sayings justified in continuing that no
reason not justified I'm not judging I'm
not saying he's justified he shouldn't
do that I respected George Bush's
approach I think that approach President
Obama should take president Vice
President Cheney was much more
aggressive and negative about the Obama
administration for the entire time and I
respected George Bush's approach now
okay so I'll go to you let me go to you
Larry
what say you we're talking about
presidents not vice presidents and Obama
undid the signature achievement of
george w bush and that was the war in
iraq when the george bush left office he
assumed that there was going to be a
stay behind force between five or ten
thousand troops had predicted what would
happen if there was a vacuum obama comes
in pulls
every single true and george w bush
didn't say one word as things got worse
in iraq as he predicted it is certainly
true that Vice President Dick Cheney
said something but george w bush didn't
say a word
ronald reagan retires he goes to simi
valley doesn't say a word George Herbert
Walker Bush goes to Kennebunkport
doesn't say a word George W Bush goes to
Crawford Texas doesn't say a word Jimmy
Carter Bill Clinton Barack Obama never
stopped talking a very different
perspective Republican versus a
difference ex-president
and you know what Austin he may have a
point it seems to be the Democrats
coming out to and and I just say go
ahead good what III don't think that
that's quite accurate
the only thing is Donald Trump is unwell
it in the sense that Barack Obama did
not mention President Trump by name now
President Trump nobody in the country
we've talked about take a lesson in
appropriateness and lack of insulted the
reasons not to insult people from
President Trump he campaigned his entire
campaign was built on personal insults
of his opponents and saying about
speaking about the extreme stupidity of
everyone yes you Austin with all due
respect that's not the issue were
talking about we're talking about a
president who comes out at during
midterms and during his last at the end
of his office to do continually attack
the President of the United States and
is something different I'm gonna give
you the last word Larry elder well okay
okay say Austin if it makes me any
happier Austin when President Trump
retires in January of 2025 with his 50
million Twitter followers he will
probably have a thing or two to say
about his successor well we'll see but
Happy Thanksgiving you too